los tampa bay buccaneers de tom brady
los escasas y de chips the matrix
homes jugarán el próximo 27 de febrero
la edición número 55 del super bowl los
aficionados de los buccaneers celebraron
en la noche del domingo la victoria de
los suyos ante green bay en la
conferencia nacional un sorprendente
triunfo esta es la primera vez que
alcanzan los players en 13 años y además
harán historia como el primer equipo que
juega el superbowl en su propio estadio
en kansas
también hubo celebración son los
vigentes campeones y anoche ganaron en
la conferencia americanos buffalo bill's
para buscar repetir el título algo que
no ocurre desde el 2004 escuchemos a sus
estrellas tom brady antigua hands worker
y me encanta venir a trabajar cada día
con este grupo de chicos
hemos trabajado realmente duro para
llegar a este punto y es un partido
difícil hemos tenido un par de partidos
duros de manera seguida y el próximo
también lo será será una gran
experiencia para mí salir y tener la
oportunidad de repetir y hacerlo ante el
mejor es algo especial y estoy
emocionado por esa oportunidad